It's great to welcome back to the program
today. Andrew Sidell, who's a civil rights
and constitutional attorney with the freedom
yeah.
From Religion Foundation where he serves as
the director of strategic response works to
keep state and church separate. His new book
is the founding myth why Christian nationalism
is UNAMERICAN. Andrew, so great to have you
back on. Thank you for having me on. It really
is a pleasure. I appreciate it, David. So
we recently did a story which was called something
like the founding fathers were progressive
and you should be too. And with, without getting
into the sort of politics of it, there is
this idea of which was part of that story,
uh, that uh, we did our best to debunk, which
is the idea that because all of the founding
fathers were Christian, that there is either
some explicit or implicit reasoning behind
saying the United States is fundamentally
a Christian nation. Now before we get to part
two of that, the first question we have to
ask is we're the founding fathers, actually
Christian. What we've found is that while
they were mostly deists, they were not actually
mostly Christian as is often described. But
my question to you is, does that even really
matter in figuring out whether the United
States should have this sort of a motto or
umbrella term of being a Christian nation?
Is the, is the religion of the founding fathers
even relevant to that? My contention is
that it is not, and this is the argument that
I tried to make in the founding myth. It's
a really interesting conversation and it's
fascinating to delve into the beliefs of the
founders. But when you're talking about, well,
is this actually a Christian nation? It doesn't
matter. Uh, so if it, let's say, let's just
agree for a second, for the sake of argument
that all the founders were these bible believing
Jesus rose from the dead Christians, you would
still then have to connect those beliefs to
the founding of the United States. And just
because somebody is religious, their religion
doesn't claim ownership over every other idea
that their mind generates. A, you know, for
instance, blue jeans were invented by two
Jewish guys, but we don't go around calling
them Jewish blue jeans. They're just blue
jeans. Will you Shan
the Youtube comments I get before you say
nobody's doing that. But yeah, I don't think
we shouldn't be doing that.
Yeah. And we can, I don't think we can judge
everything by the youtube comments. Cause
they do. Yeah. It's a generates quick down
there. Sorry everybody. Um, but the larger
point I think is you would still have to connect
it to the founding and you can't do that.
And when you look at what the founders talked
about and believed and actually wrote into
the founding documents, they really did believe
in the separation of state and church. They
were trying to keep religion out of government
and government out of religion. And those
were kind of, that was kind of one of the
big ideas that was unique to America. It was
the first time that that had been put into
practice. And it was a, I mean, it's the,
it's the American invention then probably
our biggest contribution to political science.
And we ought to be proud of that fact as Americans
proud of the separation of state and church
ended proud of its progressive leanings I
think as well.
So, uh, if, if indeed the original founders
did not have this belief of, of sort of Christian
nationalism as the basis for the United States
of America, and now there is a wing of the
American political sphere that does have that
belief, at some point, something made that
belief start among a certain wing of the American
political sphere. Where did that start? Where
did it come from? Where, where did this idea,
this talking point that became a very prevalent
in certain political, uh, circles start from
if not with the actual founders.
All right. That, and that's a fascinating
question. So Christian National Christian
nationalism is really this idea that the United
States not only was founded as a Jew, as a
Christian nation, but it was founded on Judeo
Christian principles. Yeah. And empathy. The
coda to that is that it needs to return to
those principles. So really, and that is the
best, the driving, motivating force for Christian
nationalists. They're trying to get this return,
this and its golden age thinking really except
that the problem for them is that we never
were founded as a Christian nation. So you
saw it really ry, the rise of Christian nationalism
began with sort of the rise of the moral majority
and it wouldn't, it didn't really get that
name Christian nationalism until the mid two
thousands and it was always sort of this impotent
little sideshow, a on the fringes of conservative
politics on the fringes of conservative religion.
Uh, but that all changed with the 2016 election
because Donald Trump rode a wave of Christian
nationalism into the highest office in the
land. I mean he is not president in spite
of his Christian nationalist leanings and
rhetoric, but because of that Christian nationalist
rhetoric.
Yeah. And that gets us to making this distinction,
which is an important one between someone
a bit between Christianity, so to speak, and
Christian nationalism. Because I think as
many have obviously pointed out, if you compare
Donald Trump's philosophy and the way he's
lived his life to the, the sort of Christian
Bible, you see a lot of contradictions there.
You see a lot of problems. But ultimately,
most evangelical Christians did vote for Donald
Trump. And it seems to me, Andrew, and correct
me if I'm drawing a wrong, that underlying
it, is that even though Donald Trump may not
have personally lived his life as a Christian,
the nationalistic undertones of Donald Trump's
campaign are in line with this broader idea
of Christian nationalism. That seems to be
kind of separate from one identifying as a
baptist or, or, or as an evangelical for example.
No, that's absolutely right. And it's really
important that people understand that the
number one predictor of whether or not somebody
would vote for Donald Trump and the 2016 election
was not political party and it was not their
religion. Uh, I wasn't even whether or not
they were racists, socioeconomic status, none
of that. The number one predictor was whether
or not somebody believed that the United States
was a Christian nation. So Christian nationalism
was the best indicator of whether or not somebody
was, would have been a Donald Trump voter
in the 2016 election. That that is pretty
iron clad. Now, Andrew Whitehead out of the
University of Clemson, uh, has done a number
of studies on this. It's, it's very clear.
So Trump wasn't tapping into even the Republican
party or even into the Evangelical Movement.
There's just happens to be a huge overlap
between those two and Christian nationalism.
That was really what he was tapping into to
win this election.
What about this? A little more, um, amorphous
idea of the, you, you alluded to it already,
Judeo Christian values, which is we can, we
can slice and dice the exact religions of
the founders. We can talk about separation
of church and state in some kind of formal
or legal sense, but it's undeniable. Some
will say that the sort of fundamental moral
infrastructure of the United States was based
on the Judeo Christian. And really to that
means Christian because there were almost
no Jews who were part of this group. Mostly
Christian people. Uh, Christian Christian.
In terms of the values, again, not in terms
of necessarily identifying as Baptist or whatever
the case may be, who said, we want to leave
England and settle the new world in order
to have full religious freedom. How do we
take on that argument, which is a little bit
more nebulous and blurry?
And that's exactly what I tried to do in the
founding myth. And it is more nebulous and
blurry and that's why it's the fallback position
if you can push back on, were not founded
as a Christian nation. The next argument you
always get is, well, I really meant we were
founded on Judeo Christian principles and
that's really what the founding myth pushes
back on. And so what I did was I actually
compared the Judeo Christian principles from
the Bible. I looked at every one of the 10
commandments and then I compare those to the
founding principles of the United States to
those elements of political science and political
philosophy that the founders used to actually
build this country. And I, I, what I discovered
was not just that Judeo Christian principles
didn't influence the founding, but that they're
fundamentally opposed to the founding of the
United States. To give like a one or two examples
of that if you can.
I mean, the best example would be let's just
focus on the first, first commandment. The
first commandment is I am the Lord your God.
You shall have no other gods before me. It
runs completely counter to one of our founding
principles. Religious Liberty. You can worship,
no god, you can worship a hundred. God's,
uh, you get to have free religious liberty
in this, in this country. And if you were
to follow the 10 commandments, you only get
to worship that biblical God. And that's it.
So there's this fundamental conflict. So it's
not only that we weren't founded on Judeo
Christian values or principles, but it's a
good thing we weren't otherwise, we wouldn't
have the values and the freedoms that we so
cherished today.
So if we decided to cherry pick only the areas
in which maybe there does seem to be significant
overlap between the sort of founding values
in Christianity, just as a thought experiment
for a second, um, we then get to the problem
of sort of correlation and causation. And
I've actually heard a number of, of, uh, of
thinkers point out that, um, just because,
uh, most of the individuals who made big advancements
in, for example, stone tools, a metal tools
maybe is a better example, were adherents
to a certain religion. That doesn't really
give us any causal case for the religion being
a factor. It may just be that at the time
there was a sort of default to a particular
religious belief, so to speak. A lot of the
values that do seem to overlap between the
founders of the u s and Christianity are values
that existed much more than 5,000 years ago
in human societies. Anyway. So then the question
is, are they really even Christian values?
And, and that's a really excellent point.
And it is one that I do make in the founding
myth in a couple of different places. Uh,
one thing that we often hear is, well the
United States was founded on the golden rule
and I think that's a hard argument to make
actually, but I just assume for the sake of
argument in the book that that is true. But
then the next question is, well, is the golden
rule really a Christian principle in my argument
is that it's not, this is a universal human
principle that every successful society we
know of has developed on its own. I mean,
a two, three, four year old child can understand
the idea of reciprocal morality. It's really
not a difficult concept. And to allow Christian
Christianity or even Christian nationalism
to claim it as its own is, is to me a form
of arrogance that, that, uh, I don't think
we should allow to stand.
Can you talk a little bit about slogans? Like
in God, we trust on money or one nation under
God or the addition of a, of a reference to
God in the pledge of allegiance and the role
that those slogans have in perpetuating these
ideas of the United States as a Christian
nation.
I mean, they have a huge role in perpetuating
that myth and the role is deliberate. Uh,
so you know, one thing that I think maybe
our side is pretty good at when it comes to
pushing back on those, those mottoes is pointing
out that none of those are from the founding
generation. But then we tend to leave it at
that. And in the founding myth, I really wanted
to go beyond that. I, so I explore how these
phrases entered our vernacular and it turns
out that they were deliberately put there
during times of national fear and strife when
you had a few, a very few, a handful in each
case, Christians, Christian nationalists,
we would call them today trying to use their
public office to promote their personal religion.
Uh, so, you know, you have this happening
during the height of the civil war when the
country's literally tearing itself apart and
people aren't paying attention to what's being
inscribed on the coinage.
And yet basically three guys responsible for
getting it all in there at that point. Uh,
the same thing was happening in the 1950s
where we ended up with the national day of
prayer and under God in the pledge that it
was this time of national fear. And so it's
not just that they're taking advantage of
a country that's scared and fearful, but they're
also wiping out unifying sentiments with religion,
which tends to be really divisive, you know.
And so our original defacto motto was e Pluribus
Unum from one people, uh, or from one from
many people, one nation from many states,
one country. And they wiped that out with,
in God we trust. And the same thing happened
with the pledge of allegiance. It used to
read one nation individual, indivisible, which
is this beautiful sentiment. And then they're
literally dividing the indivisible with God.
Uh, so it's not just, they're taking advantage
of times of fear and strife. And then they're
wiping out unifying sentiments to promote
their personal religion.
This is Shay seems way bigger to me than partisan
politics in the sense that, okay, I mean there
are candidates whose philosophy is, uh, more
of a departure from the sort of thinking that
gets you to Christian nationalism. So, so
there are differences. I'm not pretending
that Trump and Biden and Bernie are all sort
of like the same on this, but, but in a sense,
this is a much bigger cultural thing. This
relates to the courts and the supreme court
in ways that that kind of transcend many decades.
So how does something like this change in
a country when who we elect is only like a
small piece of it?
And you're, you're absolutely right. And right
now it's infecting all kinds of policy policy.
We saw it in the Muslim ban education policy.
Betsy devoss is essentially trying to dismantle
public education. Uh, all of those are on
the back of Christian nationalism, our foreign
policy. We're seeing and you are right that
courts judges and not just Trump judges are
deciding cases based on some of the myths
and the lies that I try to expose in my book.
But you're also right to say that it's bigger
because at its most basic level, what this
is is an attempt to redefine what it is to
be an American. They are trying to say that
to be an American, you have to be a Christian
and to be a Christian is to be an American.
And once they've redefined the American identity
like that, they're going to redefine all of
our laws accordingly. And to me, that is one
of the central reasons why I say that Christian
nationalism is an American. It's not just
that those Judeo Christian principles often
are directly opposed to our founding values.
It's that this entire movement is meant to
redefine what it is to be an American in an
American way.
We've been talking a lot about the content
of Andrew Seidel's new book, the founding
myth, why Christian nationalism is UNAMERICAN,
but there's much more a great stuff in it.
Andrew always great to talk to you and I really
appreciate your time, David. Thank you so
much. It's always a pleasure.